[Music]
in deadly oral news oh she actually blew
into oh my god and if my dick blows now
I'm nice try
like a [ __ ] elephant not today I bet
you get the spit every time to submit it
by ah
oh nice that's what this mister a man
wants to show his penis in court to
prove that his girlfriend choked to
death during sex
oh [ __ ] oh so he was like literally
face-fucking her your honor and I please
pull out my penis yeah so this story is
about Richard and Francisca and Brazil
you want to go through here in the world
are you thinking of porn you watch with
big no I would just think I don't know
why I thought if golf that's why me at
me in Colombia in Miami
just cuz their name is Francisca yeah
your car California I knew we're gonna
be in the world yeah so body bland
touching the ocean so Richard who's 65
years old
Oh mm-hmm had been dating Francisca who
is or was 60 years old oh we got a young
not really Vijaya apparently they had
been having sex and according to Richard
she accidentally choked on his very
large penis during sex he has to show it
in court I don't understand how that
happens because once you stop like she
didn't accidentally choke on you
accidentally held her and all her head
there yeah well maybe they were into
that rough ass [ __ ] and then yeah so he
is using the it's rough sex defense in
court that's what he's saying
yeah I mean she can't say the safe word
what's the safe word necessary what's he
laughing during the court at all cuz if
you can if you can hold your laughter
and say Your Honor can I pull out my
dick to show the evidence and if you can
say that straight-faced then it's the
truth I don't think any person can say
that I see where you go yeah cuz I would
be laughing if I was like how the [ __ ]
do I [ __ ] my way out of this
I was not laughing in the middle of
seeing it right oh is it lawyer that
presented it to the court so the lawyer
wanted to see his dick no he said the
lawyer saw his lawyer if you look at
your clients big you probably do not
that revenge yeah real tough man goddamn
you packing [ __ ] if I show this
so we got this case yeah so yeah that's
the reason why they want to show penis
and coffee okay can you jump you guys
yes good
thank God it was rubber yeah so that's
the reason why they want to show his
penis in court but so the night of once
she died they're saying that Richard
just must have panicked or something
because he didn't notify anyone of
francisco's body until way hours later I
don't know how many hours hours later
hard to explain to people maybe huh
yeah and so I guess that same night he
was trying to pull his dick out of my
mouth still oh she was still attached
yeah if it's that big it's lodged in
there oh my god slow still yeah how do
you tell her kids about that [ __ ] - it's
like your mother died choking on my dick
that's when you have to make up a story
your mom was in the CIA and the most
crazy and she was posed as a hooker and
she took a big dog to the throat but
remember she was in the CIA you probably
can't hear him that fart rises here I'm
giggling but this is no funny situation
it's [ __ ] up for her and her kids play
that's funny my dick I know that's
fantastic yeah so Richard had sent his
daughter a text that same night saying
your dad did something really bad last
night and I'm so so sorry
so with that text and then go home now
that was another text that he sent to a
close family friend saying my meds are
making me crazy and I can't function so
that's what he had texted people this is
after he choked her to death yes
do they know like the form of a fixation
like if like there's all clearly no
marks around her neck there wasn't you
know what I mean yeah well and they do
like autopsy and there's just yeah
losing from inside out yeah well they're
they do claim that there isn't any marks
on her neck or anything but the medical
examiner couldn't really he couldn't
really determine it because the body had
already decomposed to the point where
bruises really were really hard to see
well so just it's purple all over yeah
so then um the medic
also said that it's hard to really
determine what was the cause of death
also did they examine his dick well
that's why he the defense is asking like
can I show my penis in court is there a
picture of his penis I'm interested in
now well the the lawyer did say that if
the judge denies it then you shouldn't
whip it up then he's considering he's
considering creating a mold out of his
peanut it's a show that would have been
that should have been his first you know
no because that could be a mode of
someone else's yeah so they still have
to end up seeing it I know but you could
present that first and then if they
don't believe it then you would put your
day well here's the thing
are we debating length or girth I think
it's gonna be a wide dick yeah it
doesn't have to be wide to black and air
passage I mean like soap you can do it
if it's long enough it could just block
it yeah yeah I'm saying like you
couldn't get it through the nose I'm
picturing like one of those burrito
challenge burritos the ones where you
like you have an hour to eat it and then
if you eat it you get the burrito for
free can we see a picture of her against
one of those like curved ones that just
blocks goes in and then blocks it like
well wait why is that mean she still has
her nose that's I'm saying if it's in
her throat you know you had a large dog
you know it won't go there he does he
has the confidence in his face syska oh
she looks like she says a big mouth not
trying to be funny calm being lawyer
yeah she has a big mouth
so what could have happened look at that
glove look at the mullet on this [ __ ]
he has the confidence of like touching
the floor did I mention they were only
dating for four months no yeah only four
months and a neighbor of hers has come
forward saying that she wanted to break
up the relationship before she died Joe
I hope I don't look like that when I'm
65
what pink skin with white hair no he
just looks a lot cuz might because what
my dad's like 60 he looks nowhere near
that old you know I mean yeah the same
age my mom is 65 I think around there
here I think I know what happened
he tried to kill her but with his dick
so he could try to use that defense
later he did a hell this pelvis two-face
dig down throat can't breathe through
nose because his pelvis is all up in her
[ __ ] right there
oh that's what happened yeah [ __ ] you
buddy if you're choking on something
through here
you still can't breathe through here
because it has to go through oh yeah
yeah yeah true yeah and another thing
that makes them look even more guilty
the fact that when they discovered the
body she was facedown she had blood on
her hands was it blood and they also
discovered a lot of paper towels with
blood and semen water own in the trash
yeah
[ __ ] how does he come back exactly what
I was thinking unless he came multiple
times oh that's true well when you find
semen at a crime scene it's not like a
full load it's constantly coming out I'm
a dick spurt come on if he's forcing it
down there he could make her bleeding
and what's the word internally they
should really check his dick for razors
she was probably like trying to pull it
out got blood on her hands he forced it
back in I think you did I think he did
on purpose
I think wick figure it out yeah I agree
and the fact that he didn't notify
anyone so he actually ended up calling
his lawyer first
no oh that is also the white demon yeah
that's what oh I mean do ya really you
know all the white people call lawyers
first they don't stop just they were
born yeah they're the only ones who you
know to say I want to speak to my lawyer
oh yeah since first grade I've heard
kids go I'm gonna sue yes they call his
lawyer first the lawyer was the one who
contacted authorities to go find her
body yeah how good is like this is what
we have to do so her son is even saying
that the defense strategy is just the
desperate man trying a desperate tactic
that he's just trying to get off the
hook oh boy her son other's a his
that his own son I was like damn even
his son hates him no it's her son oh
that's pretty crazy though I wonder
what's gonna happen if he goes to jail
I've got people in the plot or some [ __ ]
I know he's a woman killer no I'm saying
like hey Slater with that dick bro like
is he gonna get I feel like it's not
that big I feel like he just thinks in
VR you know guys think they kind of like
fluff themselves up and I feel like the
judge like I whip it out and it's like
four point five inches is hard yeah oh
so did you see this 10-inch dick it's
like this you don't see it hope you guys
enjoyed that episode if you guys have
any juicy little gossip details and you
guys wanna submit it well guess what you
can cruise on over to the description
box below click on the link submit the
story and hopefully we will pick it and
talk about it for more videos click
right over here